hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
we are getting back into it I hope you
guys enjoyed my epic struggle against
the awesome twins who fought valiantly
but in the end I was too much and
overpowered them incredible you could
say that I am you won't say that okay
I'll say it so one thing that I would
like to say I did get a lot of feedback
on the 60 frames per second because they
did upload in that for the past videos
but unfortunately I will be returning to
30 frames per second for this
playthrough at least initially and
here's what I I know that it does look
great it does look great for a lot of
people but 720p 60 frames per second is
literally the only option that it
presents on YouTube when I upload it and
it requires double the bandwidth as
would be logical and a lot of people's
Internet's can necessarily handle double
the bandwidth I mean I have great well I
don't have great internet but I used to
have great internet like hundred
megabits per second down but
unfortunately I couldn't even load
YouTube videos because for some reason
it works wonky with some people's
internets
so for the sake of everybody's enjoyment
I'm gonna make sure that this is in 30
frames per second for the rest of this
series now that doesn't mean that I'll
never do 60 frames per second again in
the future it just means that I'm gonna
play around with it I'm hoping that I'll
be able to do 1080p 60 frames per second
once I'm able to record that and then
that will be an option and hopefully
720p will be at 30 frames per second for
those that want to do that now that
sounded pretty complicated where the
hell am I going did I go the wrong way
I kind of forgot what's wails oh oh I
did I did I did okay sorry I was just on
a big rambling rant I just want to make
sure that the experience of watching
hey baby long time no see
looking good looking real good I just
want to make sure the experience of
watching these videos is the best for
the most people possible and it's not
like 30 frames per second is bad as far
as the experience goes it's actually
pretty good hey oh hey whoa hey whoa
uh-oh you give me a good view of your
crotch but I'm not sure that's
appropriate for the kiddies watching so
you stay in your little arena of death
I'm gonna go okay so don't know in how
we are now let's think about this game
like I have no idea where we're going
it just has a theme of being kind of
concrete in mechanical a little bit
electricity thrown in plenty of sewers
can't have too many sewers
well that's a bad sound what did it do
Oh oh that's bad
oh that's the bad thing I did so don't
go please go go go go go right now No go
go go please go go go go go go right now
go go okay
go good thing upgraded my spread yeah
what does that do nothing okay
all right then what the hell is
happening in this place spread please
yes Kabam I know well who are you okay
thank you go away please whoa whoa whoa
nope go that time for you
it's done with you yeah man I'm strong
how did I do that
how did I throw that on the wall did I
do that
I'm so incredible all right all righty
then well as I talking about before
anyway someday I'll have great internet
and that means I'll be able to upload a
1080p oh man
well the first episode I did when I did
720p one hour long 60 frames a second it
took me seven and a half hours to upload
the video I had to do that overnight is
one video
my internet is here I don't know what
that did okay then that did nothing all
right
high voltage well
go shoot that no oh I do well that was
kind of unexpected I didn't really think
that was gonna happen that way
whoa whoa whoa okay so I voted to keep
out I need to turn off the voltage
somehow okay then
all right all right all right I'm gonna
run past you
don't mind me Tomomi don't let me crawl
over this way lady lady would you go go
alright then she's gonna pop up I'm
Angie that's actually gonna be slur okay
why is that happening
watch this
where you lady oh don't come this way
okay
where you go lady get over here
not bad why
[Music]
yeah yeah come on yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah totally cause mix gross
yeah come get me oh oh oh it's already
out what the poop I thought it wasn't
out there was like
whoa okay well alrighty then
I need this okay okay okay wait a minute
one one one one one one who now
why why did I do that please burn up oh
god damn it why
I'm suppose to preoccupy her
[Music]
it's stressful lady stressing me out a
lot we should slow today
I see like a port that I could shoot but
there's nothing in it no no damn it
there's got to be another port or
something that I can shoot no oh god
damn it's just a timer why why why why
what do I do
why what do I do what do I do
Oh was that not right come on
oh god I'm dead out there
okay then
it's gonna feel this wall of it while I
stand here confused
on fire that places fire I'm dead aren't
I
I did something wrong yeah it's
[ __ ]
Oh oh no I'm dead okay well okay let's
try that again with less second that did
not go well I was in a bit of a panic
with the lady coming after me hair I
need a haircut
I know I need it badly it's been very
very busy I've been able to do it oh
come on really I'm back here why why
this time I want to get to this
[Music]
all pip you was with this Pope Amy don't
know
no don't oh you you you you you you
almost didn't you know what I'm supposed
to do
deal what's a doing lady
what's the doing
yeah yeah come over here right over what
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't yell weird only its
Donna sign us up give me giving him
[Music]
crazy lady
come on I'll get it
Sam you can't escape your fate that's
right I meant
what you're not burnt up come on come
after me
No
yeah yeah I've got damaged wine
i funds that what uh what are we doing
here
Kenny oh god there's a valve right there
all right we're good right
I think anyway
that was so easy before they should've
known but they didn't see it
deserving enough alright there we go
there we go
checkpoint I was that close to a
checkpoint how much I suck less I hurt a
little
what does that do I do anything
don't know why I did that oh god oh god
whoa whoa whoa wait okay wait a minute
okay here we go five whoa
all righty then come here lady
I'm gonna distract you with something
burnt up where's my things hey okay I
could screw you with your tips
[ __ ] oh really
come over here
looking for more faces she
oh it's close realize that how many
times does that happen that's been don't
don't
okay there we go go go go go no no no
Lego Lego I'm strong
[Applause]
okay Rhodey all right so you're alive
that's the important thing
in all actuality he might be dead I have
no idea maybe he's inside the mine he's
lost his body he's just in some ethereal
vortex of technology that combines them
all together whoa
Rubick thank you I don't know Sebastian
I know who you are I know what you crave
what you fear will you be able to live
with yourself knowing what I'm gonna
make you do poor little Joseph couldn't
too bad they dragged you into this
would either way your mine to do with as
I please
weirdo so he wanted to kill me before
but now I just wants to play with me is
that will stay from this ah I still got
the lady's arms in here it's a nice
touch
nice feature we just heal up real quick
splat ow toast key what other [ __ ] you
have in store for me one of the magical
things could happen to book her
Sebastian am I gonna see Jojo again am I
gonna have to deal with Jojo again you
mentioned Jojo this is a long elevator
and I guess I can just sit here and
relax take a drink kick back enjoy life
[Music]
mmm [ __ ] back here again
yeah back into rythmics Rebeck Rubens
revin Ruben rabba room and mine Rubens
mine looks like the save point isn't
here he's even open no I bet they're all
locked up aren't they yeah I guess the
only way to go is downstairs anyway
because it was the only place that had
lights
it's obviously guiding me down that way
I'm still gonna break your [ __ ]
take that ruvik huh suck on that I bet
that was very valuable or something I
don't know I know can I break anything
else of yours I'm probably just popping
whoa oh god not again
hey yo hey hey you you know why met back
here why am I just looping through all
this all right whatever I'll carry on
carrying on
is that typing okay I thought it was
bone-crunching for a little bit there I
thought it was bone crunching oh okay
all right I got you
okay then doc what the hell do you think
you're doing trying to save us really
because it looks like you're making
another monster to me I don't have time
for this detective
neither do I
[Music]
Leslie has been here before and made it
back he survived being linked pyruvic
the only patient ever as far as I know
wonderful what does that have to do with
any of this
he's our way out detective our only way
back
[Music]
it's working
[Applause]
[Music]
that's bad and we're back here again
Leslie are you alright it should have
why didn't it
yeah I didn't it oh that's bad
methinks that's Rubik guardian and he
don't like you messing around
oh wow you are a pretty pretty thing oh
[Music]
oh okay
why okay so ruvik wants out I have an
idea I have a theory I have a theory
oh oh I feared oh I have a theory Rubick
isn't himself anymore
Rubick once what else to get him so that
he can take over one of us is that what
we're dealing with here
hello
okay then rather instantaneous
transition huh
okay hey buddy how you doing because
maybe you never know a scam terminal
never thought he'd go that far
wait stem ah must be close if he's
severing ties with the past all he has
left is his connection to the present
the full stem in the hospital hospital
beacon mental hospital that's where
he'll be waiting for him if somebody he
doesn't get there there'll be no way out
for anyone so ya know I'm right aren't I
Rubick is trapped in his own machine
something went wrong or something went
right thank you I know I was kind of
swimming through it that must be it
right missing dr. Marcelo Jimenez chief
staff of beacon mental hospital last
seen in his office where he made a
number of telephone calls some mysteries
going on here it's tickle in the back of
my brain something right do I have
another key I don't know if I have a key
why the key I have one key I shall be
back my dm1 wha I'm gonna open this door
very slowly then take care of business
[Music]
eeny meeny miny you Yahoo okay got that
I'm back up to 11900 M kind of running
out of things that seem to be obvious
upgrades but I'll see what I can do
[Music]
moving on by lady need to go and Jack
goop into my brain you know the drill
done this a million times now so I can
get pretty expensive
when things get to the fifth-ranked they
get really expensive um see I could
upgrade melee damage that'd be stupid
sprint speed I actually pretty good on
sprint right now I don't know how much
longer I'd need to sprint ever I can't
buy that sniper rifles already high
damage don't know I need to do more of
that Oh doesn't need the beats not that
bad
brains is fine stock is fine agani bolts
that's already up to four explosive bolt
two syringe recovery yes makes rings
more valuable of course of course of
course
perfect what everyone out there is
criticizing me right now but I did it
because that chose to all right back
into the real world I want to do that
other guys it's obvious that we're all
trapped in here we're all trapped every
one of us is trapped in here why look
obviously to get Rubik out that's what
it is that's all this is it's just a
ploy to get Rubik out I guess that's
mines my theory I may not be right about
that I may be totally totally off-base
well hello there nice grundle alright
then
although I still haven't recovered any
more of my normal poon boats which I
need very much because oh good I can
make puta bones right about now because
I upgraded those some [ __ ] they
better be better
yup boo boo boo okay so where are we
going
are we about to take out this doodad so
that poster must mean that dr. Jimenez
some whoa
excuse me mr. grabby hands pardon moi
yeah thanks going alright bye now
he cut through that fence like it was
nothing why did he not pursue me whoa
whoa Nelly don't scare me like that not
actually please scare me like that
how I being scared come on now you gonna
do it again good thing you're not over
here why I'm in a parking garage
one way bad well one way hi mrs. shotgun
chills damn it
what Oh God that must have sucked good
thing I didn't take it away my life no
I'm fine
totally fine come on me I'm fine
wherever going this showdown time the
showdown time it's showdown time is it
boys show downtown baby always show
downtown you wannabes
I didn't do much to you damn it I don't
have much time I forgot that I actually
pop-ups one pop to the knocker
whoa whoa whoa
[ __ ] what's in here huh it looks like a
rest eat break run come on mate gather
up the tares are you doing what are you
doing hey I got something for you walks
a lot like this hey up up below the
weight you're not there anymore okay
I was trying to do a thing there
you look fun yeah this is going well I
think I think Yolo
[Music]
well it's hurting
dammit I can't get away yellow-billed
Olli
whether it's sunny Jim
well right then why do it feel good
that's bad
I'm dead I just fell over into pieces
okay so I didn't approach this with the
proper strategy I need to run away and
hide behind things so that he can run
into them and therefore damage himself
because I highly doubt that I'm gonna be
doing a lot with my Italy Italy Billy
stop hey did that work it works cool I
like it works for me good enough well I
don't need to hide that'd be a terrible
idea
give me that do that I'm gonna get out
of here get out of get out whoa oh I'm
gonna take a breather right here here's
a good place give me you where'd he go
gonna know where I am
yay cuz they're gonna have a lot of
these I was wondering I was gonna need
them yeah okay here we go
let's try this let's try it oh yes no
idea where I am
cool cool all right
I can totally hide under a thing oh no I
couldn't I somehow think that he'd find
me eventually God he's got a knot in the
back of his head
what toi
yo yo yo come on around the corner good
good good yes I made it I shouldn't pull
on that I guess that's a good thing that
I need to go up that elevator what
exactly do I need to do right now always
come back around its another blind Oh
whoa Nelly wait is this something to do
with those red lights on the walls are
those power things and I need to get
further like the elevator system theory
whoa okay then was that really necessary
oh boy he's coming
looking for me so this is the proper
strategy because I highly doubt they'll
be able to kill that thing with the arms
I got no way that so nted haha Joseph
he's gonna go back around the other way
and then I'm gonna have a lot of time
over here he does take time
clearer and clearer and clearer so that
obviously says exit but I think it has
something to do with the power things
yeah yeah it's gotta be wait fire
extinguisher
damn it damn it damn it that's not right
whoa okay well sorry buddy
didn't mean to do that nobody didn't
mean to I mean I totally meant to do
that
work
wait
[Music]
Myrtle Circle now okay well what the
hell happened yeah yeah all right yeah
what the hell am I supposed to do
[ __ ] are you on a go brah you want to go
huh you wanna go bruh you want to go
it's too late we're gonna go anyway
oh did I throw that
[ __ ] say good god damn it with the thing
damnit
okay I need to duck tonight duh can I uh
can I uh can I uh can I heal heal heal
heal heal whoa whoa what the okay that
looks like a weak point if I ever saw
one wish I would have reloaded come on
God really I didn't see
it
oh this ain't gonna bust me here we go
[Music]
the thing that ii didn't heard is bad
goddamnit this guy
there is various give me show me show me
the money that's it that's the money
whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy buddy easy
easy buddy whoa whoa whoa whoa what are
you doing
died I got you the first not the last is
that the first one in here or that mean
the first of this guy and I'm gonna face
a lot of them in the future is that what
you're meaning 20,000 yes please
I'm gonna go go around and collect items
because I definitely didn't get all of
them in my hurry hey bus key gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme oh yeah I didn't give
me a mile on her did I get them all no I
have a strange distinct feeling that I
did not I don't know why I was able to
get away from them before and then
suddenly not able to
it's very finicky very finicky not fair
not fair
there's more shotgun shells right blimey
that I didn't see all righty all righty
all righty that looks like it might be
all she wrote no no here we go
this and you take it all right we're all
good we're good we're good
whoa one more we're good all right let's
get out of here reload it up let's go
over to where the Hubble wherever the
hell we're going to go oh I have no
control over where we're gonna go
apparently
why should I I'm just in here for the
ride oh nice picture man that is wicked
that Joe Joe in the back there maybe
lucky so I killed that guy finally I
don't know what it means to kill people
in here I mean I'm assuming it's gonna
mean that the people who are in here are
these monsters and that was just like an
amalgamation of something I have no idea
but still hey whatever I don't know
maybe there's maybe there are appearance
in here as a reflection of their safety
I'd be interesting
all right then it's my stop oh good
thing that didn't hurt me
when is the ride over man well that's
not good that's the opposite of good
that's the I'm about to drown bad yeah
get that up and swim in
dive dive dive good choice good move man
you are a smart smart guy this guy's
seriously a stone-cold badass ain't
nothing ever gonna face hi what are you
doing here
why do I keep seeing you everywhere also
no I see you over there you thought you
could escape my wrath staring at me like
a weirdo I said okay now that we're
clear now that we're very clear what the
hell is going on out here it's like the
whole of the city in on this deal or is
it just everyone in the hospital area
looks like the assignments they need
building what don't host how can that be
you can piece it together man
okay that is cool
that is really cool whoa was it all just
sinking down
crazy crazy spooky scary
all right that's creepy okay
coffee coffee coffee what does this
Dodger show no it's mine
cafe I'm trying to cut out caffeine in
my life it's not doing do well cuz I
keep losing sleep every night cuz i'm
playing videa gaymes for my living from
my whole life you know
at the end of my days when I'm lying on
my deathbed I'll look back in my life
and think about all the games that I
played
I think it was a life well spent what is
going on
falling down can hardly tell it's camera
shake it's unreal alright moving forward
I'm not missing anything important am i
answers probably yes but trying to scan
for items I may have overlooked some
did that go up or did I go down the
herbal remedies Cariah not scrip
where's elf Critias Gaza why Wow
who's getting trippin he's getting
wicked he's getting weird I mean it was
weird before any more surprises
[Music]
and
well that went all right this messed up
key somewhere back inside oh it's creepy
what have we got over here all right
then
yay sniper bullets my baby I'm almost
full up on a whole clip I got my flash
thing I don't know if that'll be ever
useful again for another creature but
hey at least I have it what's in here
wait you got for me baby
Magnum custom-made high caliber revolver
fires powerful large bark cartridges it
appears to have seen a lot of use so do
I have a second pistol now I'm guessing
that's more powerful than the one I got
looks more powerful alternative
oh no it's totally different oh okay
Wow um yeah I'll use that but I mean I
also need to use my pistol because it's
good for clearing out the little zombies
at least and doing little things so I
guess I'll just keep both got my agony
bolts
I can probably craft up at least one
more little build out and I got a bunch
of lightning so that's good that's good
okay cool I bet some people were worried
I was gonna miss that one I would've
heard that for the rest of my days oh
that was a map piece I almost missed
that maybe my pieces has just been
hanging on the walls and I just haven't
seen ya tree fitty I got a tree for me I
got an old creepy
I am okay that didn't break I think your
jukebox is broken
sounds like a monster oh it was in the
jukebox how is that where are you going
wait a minute come back hey I need to
explode your brains on the walls
well they were mind then huh I guess I
need to go out that way maybe whoa hang
on it's a second there's something to
this no it seems like that might be a
secret but I guess not all right
whatever whatever whatever I'll move
forward I'll play your game you rogue
city 17
really is city 17 with the Citadel
crawling its way through the place damn
what is getting interesting
I really really love how the environment
warps that's one of my favorite things
in games when things change I would go
through there faster than you could have
said hey Sebastian booger do it dive
through that whole room are you selling
stuff I'll take one of these a big screw
you you also you can stay alive I didn't
want to mess with you thousand what a
steal all right bye I hear someone or
something in the distance over there
well I'm gonna have to blow that up whoa
whoa whoa you want to taste the magnum
baby he's got an iron mask really oh
yeah
so supposed to hit the thing on his back
obviously what oh come on really
is he gonna blow up oh he did fourth of
July okay what that way said way too
many bullets for that little amount of
dosh so I guess I should be a little
careful about this and sneak up behind
them and stab them in the brain you look
almost normal
nope never mind you're not normal
waste to Magna bullets they're probably
very valuable or not on Who am I to say
are you doing there buddy
yeah you're all right it actually looks
like one of the set of City 17 residents
oh well can I see got buying that guy
they're all facing the opposite
direction so I'm assuming yes come on
let me let me let me let me let me I
want to do it I haven't done in so long
baby turns out he was just a normal guy
and I just stabbed him in his brain
cuz I'm cool I got it looks fun hey
friend ow
he's gonna take way too long if I go
about that way no one hears this right
no one hears anything did you hear that
if you want to get up and investigate it
maybe no
keep eating buddy hungry man need to be
fed okay thought that was gonna be a
little more stealthy but apparently not
let's go up here and blow everyone's
brains up scrubbing stealthy what'd you
do in there are you doing different Oh
alrighty then does anybody else want to
say hi I'm very friendly hi you gonna
come say hi buddy hey buddy
how you doing mom okay so that's
everyone I guess
grenade I don't think I have room for a
more do I yes I do okay
so where was I supposed to go all
stealthy maybe I was supposed to be able
to get through that
oh okay this is where I would be up here
all right you can't win I have the high
ground I also have a goddamn grenade oh
you're all you're all gonna do that huh
well party on if you have fun well
you're not dead I'm gonna burn you so
hard you also well alright I'll play
nice of you and I made things relatively
simple cobble they don't know how to
crawl I thought that grenade was
supposed to kill him why didn't the
grenade kill him do I need to upgrade my
grenade damage that's still locked so
there must have been something else but
I didn't oh this opened a separate area
that's right this is a separate head
body hey buddy what Oh
okay I should've killed you and I had
that chance which was exactly now so
where is this supposed key Oh
exactly here dear Ungh find on the old
body in the alleyway used to secure the
Mira tears whoa hello hey friend oh yeah
you're home how about I just shoot you
in the chest
get off my high ground mine
I took a few more hits than I was hoping
to hey buddy nice nice shoe me shuffle
okay I need to get my shotgun out and
just okay that guy's dead they're all
dead now they're all dead
nice to have a little bit of an exercise
oh there's more why is there more Oh
cause I need to unlock the door of
course well I'll just go that way then
they're probably gonna come a long way
around so I'll be able to just go over
there
as soon as they start hopping over this
way come along little dogies yes that's
right hop that way that's good yes yes
do that all right so I should be able to
just think this is taking forever I'm in
no hurry don't worry about me what was
that now or don't don'ts good to jump
down
don't it how about you burn how about
you burn wash and you do you like your
head not fooling around enough playing
with the fodder somehow I need to get
around obviously I just walk around
that's easy enough then I need to go
down or up I'm gonna go up first cuz I
bet this is secret up here
Oh AMRO not much but I need it and every
bullet I can get I need the little
bullets for popping the heads you know
what I'm just gonna I'm gonna leave I'm
gonna leave my Magnum in the inventory
and just pop back to it when I need it I
need one robust key all right so where
are we going now I'm imagining we're
heading to the asylum that's our end
goal but how am I even supposed to
navigate all this this is one big
confusion it's just an array of
horrifying things I imagine that Rubik
has some sort of salt false sense of
godhood that he's able to do all this
junk but in reality he ain't do not okay
then I was gonna sneak kill him now he
snuck dead
yeah more bullets take it okay / we go
alright I'm just having a good old time
don't mind me yeah sounds bad
okay
alright then that looked like the
Leviathans straight from half-life
we're not even beating around the bush
anymore so it's like the water monster I
need to feed them bodies oh it's so the
water monster it's so the water monster
okay so what I need to do I need to
distract him with a body and then swim
past okay
get that one
there we go whoa always a bad idea
Oh
[Music]
get up get up get up get up hey
okay that's how you gonna be huh
yeah no new none there's another one
over there
who's they supposed to do I was going
advanced I could I was on land just
decided to really take my time strut
down the water there we'd show off my
guns for the ladies you know huh oh yeah
I'm beautiful I am them again
Oh yep we okay still distracted good
very good
yes yes yes so now I just need to take
my time over this way off that sucker go
get it okay oh it's supposed to go a
little sooner
how's it a little trepidatious going in
the water there Chainsaw 3d eat my baby
okay so I obviously need to get I
obviously there's no no damn idea what
I'm supposed to get first
instinct tells me to get the far one but
I think it might be the closer one I
actually need Oh terrible idea hey okay
okay hey hey water mosses huh I hate
sharks the idea people just want to go
back in the water anytime soon
oh yeah oh you're a good one zib all
right there Adams over here give me all
right range are sliding down the hill I
haven't had a key in a while probably
missed some status' this is where a
strategy guy would come in very useful
because there's definitely a lot of hit
and goodies around here now I don't even
know what they do I don't even know if
there's gonna be like an alternate
ending if we do something
I mean alternate endings are typical to
some over games but usually these titles
alright then that didn't feel good so
not good what's happening now okay it's
getting very blue house have a lot of
goop that I need to use there was a
light by a door over here I want to make
sure that I use
what oh no you do not I knew that had to
be really well alright then that's weird
need I shoot that thing in the face whoa
okay can't kill that guy that's good
that's good just like the normal Rubik
you get popped you get popped [ __ ] you
know what I'm just gonna throw a grenade
cuz they got plenty okay bye
it's turn away
time oh then he's vulnerable he's
vulnerable when he's bleeding
most people are but this guy's
particularly vulnerable when he's
bleeding so I gotta gonna do another
thing with the thing help okay bye
I always thanks running towards me all
weird come on open your face up open
your mind up it's big every my time
I need to give them a something to think
about first where did you come from
Wow okay all right then
street sweeper I don't know if you
insta-kill I'll risk it
burn this for no reason walk over that
fire and be dismayed oh you're fine
so that guy down that lady's still
chugging
damn it not finishing him off hey doing
nothing huh looking at you still weird
still weird
goddamnit that last lady's good enough
well well goddamn you duck what the [ __ ]
there we go see down yeah nothing give
me the sniper rifle maybe I didn't Rubik
himself gonna fake yes I'm kind of not
ruvik oh that's bubbly all right so I'm
gonna burn you anyway do this because I
got plenty of matches okay I used a lot
of materials on that is this like there
was a lot of them what else could I do
even if I was a great shot actually I
didn't do too bad there like I could
have been any better
Oh what do you have for me game oh
there's something in the baby carriage I
must have missed that oh goody matches
cuz everyone knows the baby's favorite
toy is a bunch of matches good for the
whole family
wholesome fun oh wait no the opposite of
that I don't get hit once so I'm proud
of that that's pretty nice
yeah actually that's what I meant to do
I kept thinking while I was trying to do
I meant - oh god I just did an explosive
I meant to get to normals I do so much
damage with my normal ones that's bad
yeah oh okay
thanks for the rescue you gotta be
kidding no that was very convenient this
place has seen better days
filthy yeah no joke maybe shouldn't be
reading so many dirty porno mags is
doing who's doing oh boy oh he doesn't
like me having this little saggy shoe
where he does he Wow all right then yeah
anything to say buddy Oh nurse there's a
bit of a are you all right
you do realize there would be no one to
replace me um okay what is that cryptic
message of love mean missing crimson
city police inspector Arnold Brown claim
to be holding important evidence in an
unsolved case before he disappeared
so not that I don't care lady but what
the hell's going on around here come on
Sharon okay alright so anyway I am
officially all out of time for this
episode so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done after an hour
you've got to be craving more so thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next
[Music]
can't see everything's going crazy
[Applause]